high school teacher lashing out at her
students and slamming their parents over
demands that schools reopen
the teacher was recorded on a zoom call
and appears to be referencing a lawsuit
by a group of parents trying to get
children back into the classroom
if your parent wants to come talk to me
about how i'm not doing a good enough
job in distance learning based on what
you
need as an individual
just dare them to come at me because i'm
so sick to my stomach
of parents trying to tell educators how
to do their job
so i'm going to first go to proud papa
jesse on the panel
congratulations on the new the mini
jessica thank you
um i'm curious to get your take on this
uh because you have two kids who
uh are in school right now 11 year old
11 i think they're 11 year old
twins um what is your nine but it's
close
oh sorry they're very mature though
they're they're very mature and lovely
so part of what's um in contention right
now is whether there should be
even any remote learning at this point
and we now know that
certainly with vaccines but even without
that schools are not these super
spreader events what do you think
is the right balance do you think
there's any room for remote learning or
it's just like
everybody's got to get back in the
classroom now at this point uh situation
well if the kid has the sniffles they
can learn remotely that might be an
advantage to this whole pandemic remote
learning situation but no i think kids
need to be back in school
one thing is clear jessica teachers do
not like being evaluated
they like evaluating other people they
like judging and scrutinizing but if you
turn that
scrutinizing around them and question
their motives their motivation their
curriculum their schedule
any of that how much money they're
getting
no no no no no they panic and they don't
like that also another thing
we need to get back to complaining about
students we can't have parents
complaining about teachers
and teachers complaining about parents
let's go back to the good old days
where students were the issue all right
that's where we belong
happy to do that uh greg what's your
take are we going to see increased
numbers in the rubber rooms of the
public school system
you know i learned those rubber rooms
not as fun as they sound
but i think we've learned i think we've
learned from zoom
teachers hate teaching and they hate
their students
and they hate the students parents i
wonder if like
i mean i guess everybody complains about
their customers
everybody complains about their clients
but it seems like that's what we learned
at least in california it seems that
it's always california that the people
are most pissed off
at the whole process of it maybe it's
just i keep saying it's time to bail on
the system
we're seeing a really uh promising
movement of states you know wanting to
fund the
fund the uh student and not the system
you can follow corey deangelis i think
that's his name on twitter he
covers this very well but it might be
time for some real
actual i mean take it take this as an
opportunity
to create a new kind of education
because it's clear this ain't working
it's kind of depressing when you think
about it and there's no solution
it's just a bunch of people complaining
sounds like me
330 million greg gutfeld is a little
scary
katie what do you think about greg's
idea for an overhaul
no i think that an overall the education
system is long overdue
and the unions refusing to go back to
school no matter how many accommodations
that they receive
is a perfect example of why school
choice is important but i would say
i do know a few teachers who have been
doing this distance learning thing and
for them it is far more frustrating
than being in the classroom so
while there have been a lot of bad
teachers who in bad faith voting not to
go back to school and to be in the
classroom
many of them are being held hostage by
their unions they want to be back in
school and distance learning has
actually been very difficult
for everybody involved so she is uh
accountable to parents who pay property
taxes if it's a public school
but i do understand the frustration with
the the distance learning that continues
absolutely dana last word to you well
two things one um
she compares it to people going into a
doctor's office and telling the doctor
how to do their job
that's not what's happening here the
parents are not saying we want you to
teach shakespeare in this particular way
or we are saying that you need to teach
the oxford comma
or not i don't want to get into that
debate all they're saying is
we would like you to do whatever you're
doing to do it in person so that's not
exactly the right thing
also and everything will be okay i talk
about this very annoying trait
that i think will hold young women back
if they keep doing it the up talking
that this woman participates in so she's
teaching her kid the students to talk
like that don't anybody talk like that
it will hurt you in your future